if you were forced in another death game
where
that felt weird if you were forced into
another death game where the stakes have
been raised tenfold what would you do
I'm here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
Death game the swamp the casino and
kaiiji too this man is about to find
himself in the biggest death game of his
entire life playing a game of dice this
genius kaija here gives up after losing
back-to-back games he offers to pay up
the last of his cash in order to get
another turn but the dealers tell him
that there's 100 000 cash limit and
that's when they mentioned that the
limit will be dropped for one turn and
the entire room rushes in to put down
their bets on kaiiji winning the next
game the elderly dealer calls the mode
for making the wrong decision but he's
about to make a big mistake the man
throws down his set of dice and declares
himself the winner but this prisoner
picks up the dice though and reveals
that they're rigged the only numbers on
it are 4 5 and 6 meaning that these
dealers are robbing them dry the guilty
man pretends that the dice are for
practicing but it's too late the
prisoners tell him to pay the 4-1
penalty for cheating and eagerly thank
kaiji for getting them out they reveal
that one of them has been recording the
dice rolls for six months demanding that
the dealers give back all of their
stolen cash but later the elderly dealer
tells the prisoners that they can only
last one day each up top with the money
that they currently own and that's when
all the prisoners decide to have a bro
session have kaiji become their knight
in shining armor once upstairs the game
Masters handle a watch and a pile of
cash these suited men that interrupt to
question if kaiji here was responsible
for dethroning their original boss they
throw him onto the ground and announce
that he has 14 days of freedom and
around a million yen kaiji then tells
them that he's planning on making 200
million yen to buy freedom for himself
and the 25 other prisoners that are deep
down underground toiling away and highly
illegal Minds he wakes up above ground
in the middle of Tokyo City looking at
his watch he sees that the time has
already started counting down now he has
less than two weeks to turn one million
yen into 200 million yen the genius
decides to search every nook and cranny
of the city in order to find a way out
of his crippling death he finds himself
in the queue for a homeless shelter
successfully Landing a place to stay for
the night but that's when he notices a
group of thugs bullying this innocent
man they trade glances and he realizes
that this man is the ex-boss tonagawa
later he invites kaiichi to play a game
of shogi with him giving himself a
handicap to make it fair the genius
agrees to give it a try and put down his
bet tonagawa begins playing mind games
with him but kaiji here knows exactly
what he's doing that's when the shelter
announces his number on the loudspeaker
and the idiot runs off to secure his
room he comes back to the game and finds
that all of his money that he put down
has disappeared except for a note that
was left behind under the shogi board
telling him to go to to a special Casino
of patei corporation owns wow this guy's
just like Aladdin from Disney but unlike
Aladdin kaichi doesn't have any Street
smarts look around you it's not like
you're in a nice part of town you can't
just leave money lying around and expect
it to still be there when you get back I
wouldn't have trusted tonagawa with my
money if I was kaiji I would have
remembered that this guy was a part of
the company that made my life a living
hell kaiji doesn't have a lot of time he
has 14 days to make 1 million yen and
turn it into 200 million yen we'll
quickly run out of days and options if
we don't get moving quick but it doesn't
mean that we should have just rushed in
accepted the game and taken what this
guy says at face value we need to stop
and think about why this guy is talking
to us in the first place because he
definitely has an angle we're going to
play with him but cautiously and play
his little game in order to get some
answers about what he really wants the
way he described his game and even
playing with a handicap means that we
shouldn't play to went being a shogi
player already it's likely that tonagawa
will beat us no matter what which means
the end goal is not to win but to buy
time so we can draw it out for as long
as we can and get as much information
out of him as we can he was an
ex-employee of the Tai Corporation he
knows them he has information and maybe
even contacts that we can use to help us
get that 200 million yen that we need
the next day he spots the building in
the middle of a busy street he rides
this elevator all the way down and is
greeted by two agents who Pat him down
and wad him a few times and then led him
through kaiji walks inside to find an
underground operation filled with dozens
of gamblers betting their life savings
away he makes his way further in and is
then heckled a little bit by this
friendly Gambler Kotor who reveals that
these machines pay 100 times the normal
amount he then leads him into a separate
room where a frenzied group of gamblers
crowd around the casino's biggest draw
each Pachinko ball inside counts for 4
000 times the amount and hitting the
jackpot means that you get all of the
Lost balls from past losers which would
add up to a total of 1.1 billion yen
kotoro points up and shows him the only
two people that have ever won and that's
the chairman of the Tai Corporation and
another executive that's when they watch
this Gambler nearly make it into the
money hole but loses and he rushes back
to the ATM machine and takes out a
gigantic loan kaiji looks towards the
security camera and mentions that the
game is likely impossible to beat and
they watch as the now massively in-depth
Gambler quits playing tries to be cool
about it and then suddenly tries to run
away and is forcibly escorted off of the
premises but outside kaiji explains that
each ball circled five times before
falling into a losing hole and the game
can't be won with normal play the game
is rigged the only way to win Is by
subverting The house's control hearing
this kotaro brings him to a warehouse
and shows the man his living situation
he explains that he used to work as a
foreman for a construction company but
was laid off due to to a bad economy at
his wife and child left him and he
believes that if he becomes massively
Rich they'll come back well I hope so
but probably not the man begs him to
partner up with him and help him out
with his problem in exchange for a large
sum of profit 20 million yen not the
exact amount that kaiji really needs but
it certainly gets him closer and he
accepts his offer and the men shake
hands that's when kotoro reveals that
there's one more member he brings out
this shy girl yasuda who tells them that
the game Masters were the ones
responsible for her father dying now
she's looking for revenge and is forced
to work at the casino undercover waiting
for the perfect time to strike okay ah
this is crazy because while kotaro
certainly is an intelligent bloke I
wouldn't exactly call this guy smart
because he already made a cardinal
Mistake by bringing this girl into their
plants while it isn't uncommon to bring
in trained individuals for specialized
jobs AKA strangers especially in Heist
films there is a difference that makes
me suspicious as hell of this girl as
she possesses a trait that kotoro and
kaiji didn't catch and she just told us
who she is she is the daughter of Mr
Ishida the same guy that kaiji was with
while standing on a tiny beam between
two skyscrapers in the rain this can
lead to so many problems her father died
because of the casino and her coming
here to essentially avenge him means
that she is operating out of her
emotions this is the core difference
between these two and this girl and boy
doesn't make a difference because this
makes her a huge Wild Card operating out
of anger or emotional distress while
very normal means that this girl may or
may not screw up with their plans in
order to reach her end goal which
technically from the get-go makes it
very different from kaijin kotoro who
want to beat the games and become debt
free there is also another factor that
plays into her being a bad pick for this
team because she works for the casino
that killed her father and the fact that
they're getting away with it so easily
means that they have the resources and
skills necessary to keep tabs on anyone
who may interfere with their objectives
and the casino being run which could
mean that they've already begun keeping
tabs on this girl that right there alone
means that bringing her onto our team
could ruin everything by her getting
discovered prematurely all because of
who she is but even if they aren't
keeping tabs on her bringing her along
into the casino to help us carry out our
plan could be in of itself another risky
move because if at any point the casino
realizes who she is and her father's
relationship with kaiji could cause them
to take a long hard look at what they
are doing inside that casino and
everything could fall apart because of
this there's too much on the line and
check this out her body language is
strange when talking about her sob story
and how she suddenly noticeably relaxes
when these two bought her story means
that this chick was very suspicious to
begin with because not just that we
don't know her it's that we don't know
her as well as she already has some skin
in this game which could complicate
things for us in the future but in all
honesty kodral should have totally hired
way more people that he trusted to help
carry out this operation this dude is
essentially trying to carry out a
low-key Ocean's 11 type of jump and
those guys had 11 people kotaro should
have tested the operational skills of
his members by doing exactly what those
ocean 11 guys did and should have
started his gang with a smaller stake
job with much less on the line because
him trying to go headfirst and trying to
steal the Big Kahuna with only two other
people kaiji and this chick was dumb as
hell to begin with kotaro explains that
the machine has two parts and three
settings the first part is called The
Forest of nails which is designed to
control the ball's Direction he reveals
that the casino chooses a setting known
as setting a once a month meaning that
will be their time to strike the man
whips out a setting schedule that yasada
stole and reveals that setting a is
coming up in two days time he continues
by showing him a three-step Clune which
shows three holes on the first step four
on the second and five in the third this
means that their odds of getting a ball
through is 60 to 1. kotaro admits that
it's impossible to beat the game unless
you can mess with the ball's travel
route and that's when he flicks the
switch and watches as the balls travels
down and suddenly one of them makes it
through all all three steps and kotoro
shows him a magnet responsible for his
success the man explains that he plans
to hide the magnet in a beer can giving
it to yasada to hold on to it and get it
into the casino kotaro walks them over
to a diagram and begins to explain his
master plan first kaiji enters the
casino alone empty-handed while kotaro
here enters later only having money on
him and asks to play the swamp he
decides to play with the 10 million yen
limit while yasada goes along working as
usual standing at the machine the man
announces that he's about to bet his
whole wallet if he wins the entire room
will get tips cotoro Begins the game
while the others get into position the
man makes it through the first part and
hands the beer back to kaiiji he fails
to win the first round and asks for the
beer can back kaiji decides to leave the
crowd and hears everyone cheer in unison
he looks over to see that kotoro has
made it to step 3 and is about to win
millions of Yen but the man fails
offering up his last 10 million yen
stack to the game Masters he flicks the
switch and watches as his final set of
balls make it through the Forest of
death and onto the second step and
suddenly a single ball reaches step 3
and he Stakes the beer can as close to
the machine as possible it bounces off
the rim and suddenly misses the final
hole leaving him millions of Yen poorer
the man falls to the ground and the
dealers tell him that he still has a
single ball left that's when one of the
suited men stands up and notices a beer
can inside of the ball pit he picks it
up and confronts kotaro and kotaro is
[ __ ] bricks the man states that the
machine uses both steel and brass balls
to subvert cheating that's when yasada
steps up and reveals that she tricked
both of them all along hearing this
kotaro freaks out and begs them to give
his family his life his money back the
dealer admits that he was impressed by
his skills and offers him a chance to
play a different game this time he'll be
rewarded with 30 million yen if he wins
okay this is some Eight dollar Sushi
Buffet type of [ __ ] kodral should
have known better than to have assumed
that he could have somehow won a game
that nobody else had ever won before
other than the chairman and an executive
of the company this was 9 naive as hell
of him for starters if nobody had ever
won this game before then doesn't that
mean that if someone did win they
wouldn't let him leave the casino right
as ultimately we have to remember that
this place is run by Mobsters because
the dangers of playing this game
increased tenfold when playing against
the house especially if it happens to be
run by scary mobster gang types that
have control over the entire city this
is why these two should have approached
this with more strategy and preparation
the only way to beat something that
can't be beaten is by changing the rules
of the game itself in order to gain
leverage somehow and yes what I'm
essentially saying is is that kaijin
kotoro should have thought to cheat in
this game even more which cultural
already tried to do with the magnets he
already did try to cheat and while this
was a good idea in theory he should have
vetted it out better kotaro here did too
much assuming in his planning from
trusting The Stranger girl to assuming
that his idea about magnets had never
been done before was that the casino
didn't think to keep in place safeguards
against this very thing they should
approach this with way more caution and
they could have done this by hiring a
fourth person one that could have gone
inside the casino first to blow a bunch
of money and test out kotaro's magnet
theory if it worked if it didn't and why
not also it's noted that for security
reasons the casino frequently changes
out the material of their balls from
steel to brass and back and forth in
order to boost anti-cheating security
this is why kotro should have also
worked on figuring out the schedule
behind this implementation and if in
fact there was even a change in the
balls and when the machine would have
had steel balls inside of it and not
brass as the whole magnet plan relied on
this one important fact once we figure
this out though then we could have
ensured that our magnet plan would have
had a higher chance of succeeding rather
than letting some loose ends Doom it all
to fail the next day kaiji arrives back
at kotaro's house to reveal that he's
won a game of Pachinko he drops a ball
by accident and kotaro suddenly rushes
over to grab it suspicious kaiichi
pretends to sit down with the man and he
quickly gets back up and moves over to
the fridge to find a stack of money
kotaro admits that this 2 million yen is
the only cash he has left oh boo hoo he
lied to us so I say that money is good
as ours but that's when kaiji realizes
something he might have just figured the
game out he visits the casino dealers
and watches as the boss man sits down on
top of the ex-tai employee tonagawa The
Man reveals that he controls the swamp
and will make sure that no one ever
beats the game unless he wills it
akaichi you're adorable this is such a
bad idea this bad guy is part of the
terrifying corporation that kaiji owes a
life crippling amount of debt to and he
has less than seven days to pay
everything back he owes or he'll be
forced to go back and work in the
horrifying Minds while he'll work and
work until he likely dies from
exhaustion coming here to Simply make a
statement was as dumb as hell because
even if there was no way to beat the
casino declaring their intentions right
in front of these mobster's faces would
only keep more attention on them which
is the last thing these guys need but
kaiji and this guy the boss man despite
being so so different are actually more
similar than you would think this guy
used to be in the same spot as kaiiji he
used to be in debt to the Tai
Corporation same as him and now he's a
part of it and in charge of one of their
casinos the boss man eventually cleared
his debt and ended up joining the very
bad guys that took everything from him
now kaiichi off the bat wouldn't know
this but it's logical to deduce that
this Corporation employs thousands of
employees both willingly and unwillingly
and runs a multitude of businesses that
require constant upkeep which means this
company requires a constant flow of new
workers and if we've noticed the games
that this company has put kaiji and
thousands of other victims through have
been beatable but have usually resulted
in only one or two people escaping the
games alive for a corporation as large
as this one having someone with
first-hand knowledge into how exactly
this company really and truly works and
how the games work would be invaluable
to them and it makes sense to think that
the few people that have survived these
death games would make wonderful
employee because they've had to go
through literal hell in order to get to
the top by being Cutthroat and ruthless
and if I was running an evil
multinational corporation then these are
some of the exact qualities that I would
look for in my workers these people here
are all opportunistic as hell which
means it makes sense that they would try
to hire winners of their Dead games to
come work for their company as Cutthroat
employees in order to further the
company's overall agenda and quarterly
goals I'm sure and means that likely
many of the workers here were once
players of the Dead games that kaiji is
in right now which means they'll likely
keep an even closer eye on kaiji and his
crew more than any regular Casino goer
and that means that it makes zero sense
as to why he chose to go to the same
underground Corporation spot that he
owes money to he would have had much
better luck trying to win some money by
going to some other casinos as all
casinos offer roughly the same games but
with one major difference and one
difference that could help kaiji win big
in general each Casino offers a
different payout if if you win if kaiji
has a casino a and a casino B to choose
from Casino a could offer a payout for a
game like natural blackjack with a three
to two odds payout which means that the
dealer would have had to pay kaiji one
and a half times the amount of the
original bet if he won but if kaiji
chose Casino B this place could have had
the same game but with a payout of up to
six to five odds or Worse which means
that if kaiji won he would get paid six
dollars for every five that he bet in
the first place this means that kaiichi
could have increased his odds of winning
some money by not only avoiding this bad
guys casino but by finding specific
casinos that offered the best payout for
him that could have increased his odds
of winning some money sitting at a cafe
he overhears two people discussing a
nearby building project which was a
massive failure and he presses them for
further information back at kotaros they
realized that this might be their key to
success but they need money to purchase
a whole lot of balls 2 000 of them to be
exact later they find themselves back at
the casino and watch such as the floor
indicator moves upside down leaving the
lift the dealer leads them to a new room
and a brand new game he walks down and
welcomes the other guests showing them
three buttons and explaining what this
is about the princess enters one cell
while two lions entered the other ones
and that's when they bring out a former
loser of the swamp to play a game and
they chain him to the ground if he
presses the wrong button he'll be eaten
alive the man then confesses his love to
his woman and proposes to his princess
and this girl agrees to marry him when
they escape and she tells him which
button to press full of love the man
takes her advice and that was his
biggest mistake he quickly presses the
first button but watches instead as the
Lion's cell opens up he tries to run but
the chains stop him and the man is
brutally eaten alive the princess wins 3
million yet and the dealer announces one
final Challenger for the night the
spotlight shines onto kaichi's face as
he reluctantly accepts the challenge the
man walks into the pit and yasuda here
is revealed to be the princess he gets
chained to the ground and this masked
man informs the audience that this is
the same man kaiji who killed yasuda's
father he leaves the pit and the game
now begins kaiji begs the princess to
give him the correct answer but that's
when an old body of his funai bangs on
the pit door and begs to be freed
telling kaiji to pick a different button
kaiji rejects his offer and confronts
him about his betrayal in the previous
games on the espoir and that's what the
man admits that he hates the gambling
company Tai and wants to leave this
place forever confused kaiji looks
towards the princess who asks him to
press button three akaiji feels
something is off and he doesn't know
what to do I love this kaiiji here being
the adorable noble idiot here means that
he's so royally screwed this is a simple
game of Blind Faith just like the game
trust Bob up with much worse
consequences and ravenously hungry lines
who will tear you apart nice kaiji will
be forced to trust one of these scumbags
in order to escape this place alive and
win some money which is nice but if he
trusts the wrong one he'll get horribly
eaten by these lines as a result but
from what we've seen all of these people
have motives to kill us or ruin our
lives which means trusting any of them
will be risky as hell because we don't
want to end up like that poor wannabe
married dude and also Lions have more
teeth and a much bigger mouth than even
Dom and have an incredible bite force of
650 pounds per square inch and some have
even been recorded to have a bite force
of over 1 000 pounds per square inch
that is so exciting I mean terrifying to
put that into perspective you or me will
likely only have a bite force of around
150 psi which means that these big cats
will literally Crush our bones within
one bite but between all these lying
scumbags there is a way to get out of
this and figure out who will be the
least likely one to screw us over we
just have to break this down logically
this girl overhears father got murdered
by the very Corporation running this
whole [ __ ] show which means like I said
before means this lady is operating on
pure euromotion and vengefulness which
means this girl won't hesitate to screw
them over if it means getting Justice
for her daddy Because unless you've got
some daddy issues and a rather strange
relationship with your father think
about it what would you do if you knew
the person who killed your dad was
standing right in front of you and you
could do something about it what would
you do now on to this guy funai here he
ain't much better if we remember this
guy screwed kaiji over once before and
left him to be a prisoner and unlike
tonagawa who is also here they haven't
seen this prick since he screwed him
over which means it's safe to assume
that this character has definitely not
turned into Mother Teresa tonagawa here
however is the only person within this
group who has shown kaiji any sign of
decency at least on the surface and this
makes me think that he'll be the least
likely one to screw him over since he
did tell kaiji how to get out of his
debt at the very beginning of all of
this which means nice guy or full-on
scumbag tonagawa is one person who he
can trust for now since there really is
no reason for him tonagawa to help
kaiiji out at the very beginning unless
he needs kaiichi for something the enemy
of my enemy is my friend and right now
choosing this scum of the earth is their
best bet at Staying Alive kaiji Paces
around the pit wondering what to do when
tonagawa here tells him to man up and
make a determined decision suddenly he
presses button three and yasada is free
and he wins some money the man
approaches her and questions why she
stays with Tai but she walks away and
out of the pit and the door shuts that
night kaijin kotaro drink to their
success tonagawa walks in out of nowhere
and hands the genius a gift He suggests
that they become a team but kotaro
doesn't trust this man one bit tonagawa
takes kaiji outside into a building and
shows him a shortcut that he's carved
out and it's taken two years tonagawa
takes off his jacket and reveals a brand
on his arm The Man reveals that he's 40
million still in debt to Tai and is only
above ground to serve Tai corporation's
needs that's when kaiji receives a phone
call and heads back to kotaro's place
and he finds a familiar face waiting for
him his buddy explains that yasada came
back and doesn't work for Tai
Corporation any longer oh we're gonna
believe her now that's a terrible idea
the next day kotaro continues explaining
their plans and greets the girl as she
walks in and everyone decides to open up
their hearts and say that she can be let
in on their secret but yasada declines
their offer telling them that she's not
trustworthy because of her past outside
kaiji checks his watch to find out that
he's got less than 24 hours above ground
the group rolls out for their final
mission but don't realize that they're
about to be betrayed walking into the
casino they head straight for the room
with the swamp game kaiji walks up to
the machine and declares this to be his
final game the dealers then realize that
he's playing the game on setting C the
hardest setting but miraculously are
watching the balls pass every obstacle
in their path but that's when the boss
man walks in and reveals that he has
evidence of the group cheating he knows
they replace the standard issued balls
with smaller ones and orders his likies
to arrest them on the spot and the Boss
Man reveals his source to be yet again
folks you guessed it their teammate this
girl again she then whips out a
recording device and admits that she was
recording everything they said inside
kotaro's house because she placed this
thing inside the flower vase why did
nobody bother to check that why tonagawa
confronts them about using the girl in
order to trick kaiichi calling her out
for being evil and she admits that her
only goal is to continue winning which
is why she picked Tai's side the girl
tries walking out but kaiji stops her to
demand a real answer a concrete answer
of why she betrayed them Furious yasuda
tells him that she doesn't want to end
up like her father and says that the
only way to reach success is to step on
everybody else's toes the boss man
laughs at the group's reactions ordering
them to move aside so he can check his
balls and that's when he drops the
rigged balls onto a frame that will
filter out face and why watches as every
single one of them fits perfectly inside
each hole and doesn't fall through Kaiju
reveals that they've been lied to and
admits that the balls were never rigged
they never changed them out the boss
runs off in shock to check something and
kaiji tells the girl that he'll pay off
her debt when he wins the others look at
him like he's crazy but kotra thinks
he's a knight in shining armor and eggs
him on to finish the final game kaiji
steps onto the machine and begins
playing the game he starts off well and
asks kotra to pass him his second card
the crowd observes as the balls fall
down to the Clone watching him nearly
hit the jackpot and no one notices when
even more and more employees of the Tai
Corporation appear out of nowhere
watching kaiji's every move suddenly a
gambler next to the boss man falls to
the floor and drops his playing balls
and the boss man notices something he
realizes that the balls are rolling to
One Direction and realize that somehow
they tilted the entire building forward
kaiji and his buddies have thought of
every situation possible and tricks the
dealers and this guy tries waxing out
the tilt of the Clune in the opposite
direction and kaiji watches as his plans
are completely destroyed kaiji is handed
the last 10 million yen they have when
suddenly the boss man uses a remote to
change the angle of the clunes even
further one more time making the first
two clunes even harder for the balls to
pass through the genius watches as his
playing balls fail to reach the hole and
he watches carefully as one makes it
through suddenly the ball misses on the
last step leaving kaiji's plan as a
failure okay this is one of those weird
mangas with extremely long and
annoyingly specific title type of
bullcrap because while kaiji and
tonagawa here had the most insane plan
ever and it was good it got foiled by
the one factor that they couldn't have
accounted for this random drunk dude
thanks drunk guy you helped a bunch the
bad guy boss dude only noticed that the
whole building was physically being
tilted at an angle when he saw the balls
roll to one side otherwise he would
never have known this means that kaiji
and tonagawa's plan had the building
tilted enough to make a reference for
the machine but not enough for everybody
to feel a natural shift in their way due
to gravity's forces because if you ever
tried standing with straight legs on an
inclined treadmill you'd know the
feeling of standing on an uneven floor
this means that they physically tilted
the building at the perfect degree that
no one would have noticed likely about
two to three degrees to one side that's
like standing at a treadmill and turning
up the incline grade to one which is an
incline amount that you likely wouldn't
really notice that you were standing on
but once again boss man did notice the
Tilt and once that happened it was all
over this is why kaijin tonagawa should
not have just focused on besting the
machine but on all the outside variables
the people around it and the thing is
these two already knew about the Clones
these things were capable of tilting
which means they should have had a
Fail-Safe in place to guarantee that
even if they managed to tilt the
building that they wouldn't set off any
countermeasures set in place by the
casino to stop this it's logical to
assume that because this boss guy is the
boss he would be the one in charge and
in control of of any countermeasures
which means that kaijin crew should have
tried to keep him distracted using the
one distraction that has throughout
history made men and Kings alike crumble
a smoking woman kaiji and tonagawan crew
should have hired a other member AKA a
baddie woman and this person would have
been embedded within the room holding a
glass of straight vodka with the sole
purpose of keeping boss man distracted
as long as possible because this
distraction would only be temporary at
best which means kaiji could have worked
out a signal that he could have used to
tell her when she should make her move
on Boss Man likely nearing the end of
the game when the stakes would have been
the highest this smoking Baddie of a
woman would have then walked up to
Bossman to bother him as best as she
could which he would eventually have had
her removed out of his sight one way or
another and it's then my good weeps when
she could have pretended to get so angry
and throw her drink all over him and on
his face the purpose of vodka would have
been to increase the likelihood of
abrasing his cornea if the alcohol
landed in his eye and would have been
the most irritant alcohol that we could
use to temporarily blind him for a few
moments giving kaiji the chance to win
the swamp game at the last minute he
looks down in regret but suddenly has a
genius idea kaiji runs off and tonagawa
and kotoro follow in the bathroom he
asks them for all the money that they
have on them for one final push tonagawa
thinks it's all over but kotaro inspired
yet again by our knight in shining armor
hands over his last 2 million yen but
tonagawa tells him one more time that
there's no chance of Victory but kaiji
walks back onto the machine and gets
ready for his final chance at success
that's when the dealer notices something
that kaiji caught way earlier kaiji
tells him to look down revealing an
empty drain pipe the dealer made a
mistake in tilting the clunes causing
the failed balls to clog up in the drain
pipes the first Clune gets filled up
with playing balls they continue
watching as the balls pile up in the
Clune and the crowd celebrates their
Victory but suddenly kaiji stops the
playing balls from coming in leaving
only 61 left and he realizes that he's
failed everyone he doesn't have enough
money in order to make sure that the
playing balls make it to the final clone
a triumphant boss man then tells him
that he must head back underground very
soon kaiji desperately offers the boss
man a draw trying to sell him his
remaining 61 playing balls for a total
of 240 million yet the boss man laughs
in his face and orders him to finish off
the game but that's when they see money
falling from the sky tonagawa reappears
and tells him that the game isn't over
yet he left the building and took Tai's
credit card with him the man hands over
10 million yen to kaiji giving him one
final chance to beat the Tai Corporation
everyone watches as the playing balls
pile up and make it to the final set of
holes a single ball makes it through and
towards the winning jackpot when
suddenly a burst of air sends it out
everyone is stunned as their plants are
foiled again and all hope is lost
moments later the rest of the playing
balls have piled up and is still is it
enough enough to pay off their debt what
the flippity flip this has become a game
of who can now cheat the other because
the cheats keep getting more and more
insane especially if we look at the four
major obstacles that these guys have
actually managed to overcome by trying
to beat this thing starting with the
casinos continually switching out
between brass and steel balls during
their first plan then by overcoming The
Forest of nails beating the three clones
that change angles and even tilting a
whole gosh darn building in order to try
and win against this thing and even all
this wasn't enough but there's two
things that these guys could have done
to beat the swamp and it all goes back
to when they broke into the security
room of the casino as it's logical to
assume that this remote this Fail-Safe
would have been located within this room
because even if they didn't know about
this remote knowing what this
organization is capable of they should
have hedged their bets anyways and tried
to destroy everything they could have
gotten their hands on in that room where
the remote was most likely stored since
it was obviously where all the most
important assets of the casino were
located and they were already near there
to begin with if they win with this
thought of widening the hole and getting
down in there and checking anything and
everything that they could there's a
decent chance they could have found this
remote and it fudged with it by one
probably just taking out the batteries
and this would have stopped any
potential Fail-Safe from ever happening
and also it's not like this room is
massive it would not have taken them
over five hours to sift through the
stuff maybe five minutes at best and it
was a job that they could have gone away
with if tonagawa was not such an idiot
because for a guy who stated that he
spent two years digging this hole in
order to achieve his master plan the
second thing that I'm going to bring up
is this let's assume that on my first
point they don't widen up the hole and
go in there they keep the hole the way
it is why in the world did they not
bother to cover up their tracks more
efficiently because if this hole and
their tracks was never discovered by
boss man right here this dust on those
gauges then the casinos a whole the boss
man would have never discovered their
meddling in the first place being sloppy
and not tidying up their mess is what
caused for all of this to fail tonagawa
somebody should have beforehand just
gone to their version of a Lowe's or
Home Depot bought a Shock Vac with a
funnel hose attachment and and an
extension hose which then they could
have used to just snake that thing down
there and sucked up the dirt and boss
man would have never known a
ridiculously relieved boss man laughs in
kaiji's face and orders his lackeys to
take him back underground kaiji tries to
offer him another deal but is instantly
rejected he continues to beg while being
subdued by the security guards when
suddenly he looks to see yasada holding
a company credit card she offers it to
kaiji and the whole room is shook the
boss man begs her to not help kaiji
saying her wiper death clean as long as
she doesn't give him that money but she
refuses and gives Kaiju the card in
exchange for kaiji's promise of some of
the winnings and kaiji rushes back to
the machine the crowds cheer him on as
the final clone fills up and suddenly
the balls begin entering the jackpot in
quick succession the boss man curses his
luck and decides to offer kaiji the draw
he wanted offering up 300 million yen
for him to leave this game and his
people behind The Lovable loser rejects
his offer telling him that saving his
boys is more important than any cash
prize so nice the balls continue going
in by the Dozen and the crowd cheers on
as they finally beat the game while boss
man here looks as if his soul has anime
left his body the gamblers share their
winnings while the boss man is taken
away kaiji offers to give the man a
chance to beat him by going underground
he responds by telling him that this is
not over the next day the group counts
their winnings kotaro announces that
everyone is a billionaire and their
problems are solved the gamblers pick up
their cash and wish kaiji farewell one
by one he stops by the girl and thanks
her for coming through in the end but
she responds by saying that it's all
about winning ouch kaiji decides to
leave with his prize but tonagawa here
offers him one more bet they head off in
his car and he drives them to a secluded
location he whips out a box revealing an
e-card game tonagawa volunteers and
tricks kaiji into playing with him
tonagawa makes his move and makes kaiji
worried that it's a trap suddenly smoke
pours into the car and he accuses
tonagawa of pulling a prank if he gets
out the man will drive off with his
money tonagawa grabs his remote and
tries to put out the smoke bomb that he
put but then realizes that it's not
going out and has now turned into a
full-on Inferno both him and kaiji
ditched the car and watches all of their
money Burns days later he complains
rightfully so about losing his money and
wonders what to do next tonagawa hands
him 50 000 Yen and tells him to go enjoy
it with his new friends the gamblers
share drinks and have a night of
Celebration while Tona Gaba the little
turd blossom reveals the money to be
safely in his possession kaiji might
have lost his money but at least now he
has friends but what do you guys think
about the video let us know what you
like about it and what you didn't like
about it don't forget to subscribe leave
a thumbs up leave a comment down below
and as always don't forget our how to be
playlist and our social media at how to
beat anime on Instagram